when I was a kid magnetic levitation
trains maglevs were going to be the
future television shows would film
breathless reports on the latest trials
in Germany or here in Japan promising
unbelievably fast and smooth travel
between far away cities but decades
later the only actual high-speed maglev
service in the world is in Shanghai
China which is fast but it's almost a
gimmick it only goes 30 kilometers it
loses enormous amounts of money every
year and not many people use it I
thought that maglev was one of those
Technologies like Concord but we thought
were the future until they weren't and
now there's just abandoned test tracks
in the dreams of the past
which is why I was very surprised when a
local producer here in Japan asked me if
I wanted to take a ride on the new
maglev because it turns out Japan has
had a test track for years it carries
passengers because every so often they
will open their tests to the public with
a lottery for tickets and this test
track is already longer than the entire
Shanghai maglev system the plan is that
it'll be part of a 285 kilometer route
taking 40 minutes which is less than
half the time of even the bullet train
with a cruising speed just over 500
kilometers an hour 90 of that track will
be in tunnels and that's under
construction now forgive me for getting
excited but the future appears to be
arriving and I'm going to take a ride on
it but first the team here said they'd
let me stand by the track as the maglev
goes past at speed
um
my life
so
let's accelerate and then we're going to
bring it back at full speed into that
tunnel 500 kilometers an hour
that accelerates so quickly I don't know
if that comes across on camera but a
normal train would have started so much
slower than that it's already doing what
30 40K in a few seconds that that would
have pushed you back in your seat wow
okay
now we wait for it to come that way it
is
won't lie a little bit nervous I know
I'm safe
but there's a reason I'm not allowed
behind this line
it's about
maybe a kilometer to that tunnel mouth
maybe a little less
and the Train's now coming towards us
500 kilometers an hour which means
it's going about one kilometer every
eight seconds
it's nearly here apparently they've just
told me it's nearly here and I can't
hear a thing
oh I can see them like I can see the
train coming I can see headlights all
right how fast is 500 kilometers an hour
I hope that came across on camera
because you hear nothing and it looks so
far away and it looks so
unthreatening and then it is there and
this wall of sound hits you that's
incredible
I don't have wood
it's my job to have words for a moment
like this and I don't all right
um
it's going to come to a stop
I'm gonna get on it
we're going to ride at 500 kilometers an
hour
um
foreign
here we go
the acceleration is noticeable like I
got pushed back in my seat there in a
way that I think I've only felt on on
planes it's not full plain takeoff but
it's still way stronger than anything
that I felt in a train anywhere else
and we're already approaching 100
kilometers an hour
that is
and we're still accelerating
so the wheels are going to come up soon
we're going to hit 150 kilometers now
the wheel is going to come up
and the noise goes away and it's so much
smoother
[Music]
200 kilometers an hour
and we're still accelerating
[Music]
the only reference I've got now is is
the big screen
um
it's just counting down how long until
the end of the track
it's a little bit bouncy but nothing you
wouldn't expect on a regular train
okay 300 kilometers an hour we're at uh
kind of Continental Europe high speed
train now and we're still accelerating
I'm still being pushed back in my seat
not not dramatically but it's still
noticeable
I've never experienced this much
acceleration for this lot and we're
still going
[Music]
um
foreign
Ty
[Music]
will ease off the acceleration
that's 500 kilometers an hour
that's the fastest I've ever traveled on
London
feels
like a train
it is a little bit louder than you'd
expect from a train but it's way less
than an aircraft
still have a conversation there's a bit
of noise in the background but it's
still still doing okay but there's
nothing uncomfortable about this I was
worried that at this speed I was going
to feel like I was being jolted about
but this
it feels like a tree
tomorrow
so will it work this time because there
is a long history of breathless British
people traveling to other countries
getting excited about maglabs and
telling the English-speaking World about
a future That Never Comes this feels
like a video that the BBC could have
filmed in the 70s or 80s and the
original opening date of 2027 has
already been pushed back the new date is
still uncertain one local government
keeps raising objections to the
construction the future is not here yet
and we're not going to be seeing one of
these in Europe anytime soon
but the track is being built the
technology does work and it looks like
the economics are sound because there's
clearly demand for traveling between 2
and two major cities in a few years time
we might finally get to ride the maglev
that the world was promised all those
years ago
we are breaking now and it is still
fairly strong
one last thing um they they stop the
train in the middle of a curve uh when I
was coming through this at 500
kilometers an hour it felt perfectly
level to me I felt nothing weird but it
turns out that actually the whole track
is tilted 10 degrees I'm having to brace
myself to stop sliding down the carpet
thank you very much to everyone from Jr
who's standing behind the camera there
this this was a privilege thank you very
very much